欢迎收听赵华语古惑仔第1153集
今天是2026年的8月4号
以贵买来说今天是强谈的第三天
但今天的上市指数就稍稍的有点压抑了
遇到月线了
没有办法马上突破站上去
那今天我们是有影片版的
我们是有影片版的
因为我久违的老朋友
我刚刚看到他跟他讲说
我好辛苦
这段时间我都一直跟大家心灵鸡汤
你去出國
你出國的期間跌了9000點
好 那我先來歡迎他好了
我現在前面什麼都不講了
因為太多事情
我們剛剛在錄音前已經Re過了
要來問他的
好 今天來的就是我們的AI達人
蔡明翰
趙華 觀眾朋友 聽眾朋友大家好
你回來了 你終於回來了
好 我剛剛有先問明翰
我說因為他之前很訴求
就是高持股 高AI比重
然後不要隨便的被甩出去
可是 說實話
甩了9000点下来
而且很多的热门股
是腰斩
打四折
打三折
很多人就算是再有信心
看到企业的财报再好
都没有办法承受市场
这样的一个洗刷
虽然我们在过去一段时间
不断地跟大家分享说
基本面真的没问题
但是市场的情绪很大嘛
你看谷歌跟亚马逊
都是财报好
都是资本支出要提升
都是自由现金流要转付
那为什么一个是大跌
一个却创新高呢
他跟市場的氣氛
或者是當然裡面細項
我們可以來慢慢拆解
但市場的氣氛決定了很多事
還有韓國的去槓桿
韓國人的民族性
造成這一次我們可以說是
去槓桿風暴
它都不見得跟基本面有直接關係
但我們的持股已經受傷了
甚至覺得我已經被破出場了
怎麼辦呢
好
這個說來壓力大
因為這兩個禮拜
在這兩三週以來確實壓力很大
但是我覺得投資人
你會壓力很大
其實你都是從很短的角度來看
其實如果就今年的角度到現在
其實還是很樂觀的 對吧
是吧 今年指數還是有漲超過4成
沒有錯 從年初到現在
是 一年指數能漲4成
回過頭來其實還是很不可思議的數字
那純粹我覺得
應該說在我沒出過前
就一直跟大家強調
大家回 你不要每天跟著市場
去想辦法去找理由
大家根本就沒有理由
根本就沒有任何原因
純粹是漲多了
你有沒有想 我不斷的附送
上半年費半跟韓國股市漲了100%
台股漲超過五成
這都是很多都是
創了歷史紀錄的這種噴出
然後回過頭來
7月開始修正
每個人都問我說
為什麼會長這樣
這樣不對吧
我說不是 這個不太對
是第二季不對
應該說
本來就不可能永遠都有這麼強勢的長幅
每天只要進場做多單 穩賺不賠
那就是第二季的感受
比的是什麼 就是看誰的膽子大
誰的槓桿越高 贏得越多
我就常常講 這個絕對不是常態
現在才是一個常態的過程
那什麼時候會回答 老實講常常
我就副總
我覺得給大家一個觀念
我覺得這是我自己的中心思想
跟大家分享
就是說記得一件事
不管自己或者是任何人
這世界上沒有一個人
這我自己的觀念 景公分享
也沒什麼好讚的
我的意思說我自己認同
這世界上不會有人看得懂
短線的高點跟低點
這是我個人認同的
當然就是有些人說
他可以從哪裡看到
技術面什麼什麼
看到低點在哪
高點看到哪裡
我個人的論點
就是我以前各個角度都嘗試過了
我的自己的結果就是發現
沒有一個東西可以抓準
高點在哪裡跟低點在哪裡
一切都是事後才講
就簡單來講
6月22是最高點
回過頭來
也有人留言跟我講說
當時在高點的時候
我為什麼那麼樂觀
我說如果
6月22當時會保守的人
你4月5月你就保守
就是這種中間在抓這個過程
其實這個世界上
不可能有人知道高點在哪裡
回過頭來低點在哪裡
到底上禮拜四是不是最低點
也沒有人知道
禮拜五大漲之後會給大家信心
但是一定是最低點
到目前為止我也不敢有人站出來說
我就確定這個就是最低點
3萬9 不會再下去了
對 我只能這樣說
任何人都是只能邊走邊看
這我個人的中心思想
所以回過頭來
我就覺得結論只有幾個
第一個就是不用在意這個波動
那最主要的關鍵點
你要回過頭來去看
到底發生什麼事情
我說說結論就是半年來
漲了100%或者是50%的台股修正
本來就是很正常的現象
那而且我要跟大家講
到底大家常常講是不是AI有問題的
是不是經濟出了什麼問題
我說如果出問題
不會只跌漲多的族群
就這七月來再修正的
就只有台灣韓國跟廢板
你看到道瓊S&P500
歐股或港股 陸股
几乎都没有修正
所以很明显
如果今天经济真的出问题了
你以为资金会那么客气
说这个没涨的
我们就先放他一马
没有这回事
回头看一下
22年在修正
或者是08年金融风暴在修正
任何的
不管有涨没涨的族群
大家一定都是通杀
这是必然的
所以现在很明显的
就是涨多的族群在修正
所以7月一直到
从上礼拜五的现象
都可以再在证明
你可以看到7月在修正
一样的问题
在修正的过程当中
如果你持有的是
比如说飞电或者是金融股
其实你也觉得7月还好
7月修正很严重的是什么族群
就是第二季涨最多的族群
被动元件最惨了
对不对
刚刚讲到打四折三折
被动元件
所谓的功率元件
接下来也是受难的
PCB相关的有一些材料上游的
也跌得很惨重
所以都会是之前说实话
长最快最凶的一些族群
对 因为我有统计
从今年高点下来
甚至七八
甚至有接近九成的修正的个股
那其实
等于说这段时间跌很深的
几乎都是年初以来
长很多的族群
那这个故事有没有改变
答案都没有
其实这些族群都是对的
纯粹就是涨多在修正的过程当中
或者是说为什么这么剧烈
我们可以讲一个概念就是
第二季有超涨的格局
在修正的时候又会出现超跌
简单来讲
就是说我们举个例
就是说股价它可能价值就是120
那它等到它冲过120
可能会冲到180
一路都是超涨
但它修正的时候就只一路跌破120
它也杀不住
跌到100
之后再慢慢的
等於波動減少之後
才會來到它該有的價值
所以應該說這段時間大幅震盪
其實我覺得
本來就是蠻合理的現象
那我個人覺得
就是你只要一開始就瞭解到
其實這個就是漲多修正而已
然後再來就是這個
再來要怎麼操作
這個每個人的狀況就不一樣了
這個沒辦法講一個原則
套用所有人
因為就我的角度
我還是講嘛
我就是高持股
所以對我來講
我两个礼拜出国
我常常讲的 就是真的是因为
我现在有学员
所以他们每天会有问题
所以时间到我必须开一下电脑
去看一下问题 帮大家回答一下
顺便看一下昨天晚上美股
跟今天的台股
不然我以前的过去经验
我出国两个礼拜 三个礼拜
我老实讲 我连股票开都不开
对我来讲其实
我常常讲 我抓的是一个
一季一年的趋势
不会因为这一两个礼拜
出现很大的一个波动
就导致整个趋势的翻转
我这样讲
短线我还是觉得
什么东西是最重要的
就是这些个股的财报
从台积电的说法
四大云端业者的说法
甚至到辉达的说法
这个我会非常关注
因为我今天买股
就是为了这些理由
那这些人只要说法说
他们的看法还是维持不变
那自然这个修正的部分
就是涨多的一个架构
或者是反过头来讲
如果今年上半年没涨
结果现在再拼命破底
那是不是出了什么问题
我们就可以来讨论
我们确实应该要找出问题
今年涨幅出现一个不可思议的现象
而且全世界应该说
尤其是诽谤台湾韩国的人
几乎都已经没有风险意识
突然开始出现很大的压力
把一些在赚钱的时候
没有考虑到风险的人洗刷出去
這是每一次股市必然的過程
我剛剛講的
這個時間點就是檢視自己的
所謂的持股的
應該說自己的時間軸
還有槓桿的狀況
還有到底能夠承受的風險
結論我要提一個重點
上禮拜五這個架構
在下跌的過程當中
洗到市場全部都受不了了
然後終於出現暴力式反彈
這一出現很明顯
它就是两个结论
第一个过往经验
它就是最痛苦的状况已经过
因为你会再回头去看
你看到08年
它当时在下跌的时候
几乎都没有很像样的强势反弹
它跌的不会很重
它每天都得是温水煮青蛙
小跌小跌小跌
跌很久之后才发现出了大事
才开始崩跌
前段在下跌的过程当中
其实它都是每天跌一些
然后从头到尾不反弹
现在是快速下跌
出现暴力式的反弹
其实老实讲我觉得
第一个关键点就是
最痛苦的状况已经过了
我觉得几率是非常高的
可是过往经验
也不要以为这样就开始V型反弹
这个过往经验也不会出现
你看我在讲
我们不要讲这个
光在里面的人的心态会怎样
很多的人在下跌的过程当中
尤其是这个很凑巧的时间
礼拜五大幅反弹
刚好在礼拜四那天的下午
在交易的過程當中
我接到電話是一個
以前就一直有聯繫的一個記者朋友
跟我聯繫
然後他就跟我講
他說今天不是問盤
他自己有一個私人的問題
他受不了
要問我一下
他意思說
反正他就買了兩張的被動元件
然後呢
他現在已經
我看一下理論上
可能已經
應該說賠了六七成以上
然後問我說
這個該怎麼辦
我就直接跟他講結論
我說論點不變
我以前就講
被动元件它的基本面是有好转的
但股价的反应已经远比它的基本面高很多
所以在里面的人就是只能买墙
往下不能摊
但是那个礼拜四我就跟他讲
记得一件事情
这个时间点
你是被动元件在里面你受不了的
所有人都已经受不了了
所以你切记一定不要在这个时间点卖掉
那你以后之后要减码
你就要記得反彈到沒有利的時候
你把最基本你就可以賣掉
用同樣的資金轉到
整個都基本面有跟上
它的股價腳步的個股
那確實我那時候他一直來問
我就知道市場的那個壓力已經
壓力大到要打電話給一個在國外的人
對 我就知道說
真的越來越接近準備反彈的時候
果然禮拜五反彈
那我剛剛講
很多人是砍在禮拜三禮拜四
我可以相信
但是你要记得
这个市场上还有很多人
就像我那时候跟他讲
你要减码但不是现在
很多人也在等着
反弹到无力之后
要减码的也有
也还是有不少
谈到没力之后
一定他会有第二次的麦芽
再出现第二只脚
这才合理
所以应该说
目前的筹码经过这段往下之后
确实有明显的好转
但是还是有很多人
等着反弹要减码
所以可以预期未来上来之后
整個壓力慢慢的增加
尤其是看到禮拜五 禮拜一 禮拜二
反彈力道越來越小
但是我個人覺得現在不要去看
現在的觀察重點不在它指數漲低
在這些反彈的強勢族群
就比如說剛剛提到的
被動或主動或是記憶體
這些跌很深的
幾乎每天漲停的
現在的幅度是不是能夠延續
只要慢慢發現
每天漲停的個股開始慢慢的漲不上去
開始翻黑
那個時間點才代表著整個反彈的格局結束
並不是從指數
因為指數有一個很大的問題
是台積電是一個很重要的重心
那前一段時間老實講
它幾乎沒什麼跌到而且禮拜五那根反彈它還佔回所有均線 超級猛所以結論而言他扭曲了這個指數所以我常常講不要從指數的角度出發
你要從這些中小型代表型的個股
這段時間修正的七八成的個股
在這段時間反彈
幾乎大家已經六清不認
看到就是搶
所以這段時間這個氣氛
到底能夠延續多少時間
我覺得是很重要的關鍵
如果等待反彈稍微告一段落
我不斷強調就是大家還是要檢視一下
自己的手中的持股到底是
我覺得後續的問題就是
我長線的部分我還是比較樂觀
所以我覺得未來還是會過高
就是講指數的部分還是會過高
但是不代表所有的個股都會過高
特色就是往下壓的時候
所有的包含這一段時間
甚至到6月營收創立時新高個股
這一段時間還是有跌的亂七八糟
那特色應該說未來反彈的時間點
在反彈的過程當中
誰還能過高
我只能說比較有信心
就是數字是對的
那數字沒有那麼好的
也不代表說一定不會過高
但是我個人覺得說
也許未來五種五個族群
也許兩個過高
我覺得合理
不可能未來再像第二季一向
所有的族群都過高
其實今天台股
已經有一些人過高了
川虎
沒有記錯話
川虎今天過高了
AI的代表之一
因为我刚刚在犹豫说
我到底要先请明汉讲
是各个云端财报的资本支出
事实上就是订单这件事情
一个大轮廓
还是先从产业
后来明汉选择先讲被动
所以我们就先把被动这件事做了解
被动明汉的想法一直都是
他在涨的时候
他有他的道理
因为第一确实有开始涨价
第二营收确实有开始加温
但是涨一倍跟涨五倍
是不是能配得上他的营收的动能
这件事情就是明翰觉得比较小担心的
所以才会提醒说
当势头来了
大家要做被动的时候
可以就趁势而做
可是回党的话
你不要一路减一路减一路减
我觉得这个事情
在这一波你不在的时候
真的是完全验证了
但是被动到了这样的地步
它是不是有达到所谓营收成长
跟股价合理呢
可以来做一点点观察了
尤其有一个新的政策
就是证交所昨天下午公布的
储置股
因为这一次大家知道吧
被动在跌的过程中
超级倒霉的
跌着跌着就被关了
华星科被关那一天
超级惨的
跌停所死根本就没有买盘
然后呢
还跌到怎样呢
因为他还是一直跌
没有买盘嘛
又跌到二次处置
哇
那这个族群又万劫不复了
你知道吗
事实上我有听到
有一些业内主力讲说
我砍不掉啊
对不对
就是我完全砍自己的脚
我砍到跌停板都没人收
因为我就是大户啊
那怎麼辦 連大戶都不一定有全部跑掉
所以後來昨天證交所就講了
這個儲置股兩分鐘做一次就好了
大概都五天 最多七天
用這種方式 然後高價股另外看
沒有公布標準 高價股另外看
所以你覺得這個方式出來的話
對於整體被動或是以後的儲置股
會有什麼影響
我這樣講 我覺得應該
我們先回過頭來為什麼要儲置
大家先有這個觀念
簡單來說市場有點過度瘋狂
他希望市場稍微冷靜一下
然後它會越來越刁難你
讓你越來越不容易交易
希望你冷靜一下
然後讓這個股價的波動相對變小
這是過往的
它原本一開始的用意
它有一個問題就是它出手
相對有點太重的情況下
所以會導致每一次在關門跟開門的時候
股價都容易有大幅波動
那這個它現在的架構應該說
它希望這個儲分的力道小
而且老實講不是小
其實我覺得小蠻多的
小很多 兩分鐘
錯一次最多關七天
對 而且它甚至一次兩次
全部都變成一樣
所以它等於是真的這個下手
突然小得非常多
那我覺得結論而言
就是這個政策沒有一定的絕對好壞
當然第一個好處是什麼
就是未來從正常交易
到關門到開門再回到正常交易
那個中間的波動會小得非常多
所以就不會每次一關門
就突然就跌停
等到快開門之前 多多大家卡進去開門就漲停
這未來的這個情境會越來越少
這是必然的
但是他一定會帶來相對的壞處
就是你要記得人家原本這個政策
是為了讓大家冷靜
那我有個問題
未來這個冷靜的效果就會變
又會變淡一點點
所以我覺得這個沒有一定的好壞處
但是確實我覺得應該說
讓這個股價的連續性
不要這麼大的落差
就是每一次為了要關門又開門
會導致非常大的震盪
那未來應該說
我覺得啦 就是主管機關覺得
他也覺得說每次他這樣動作
可能震盪幅度太大
他先用把他這個
稍微緩解一點的方式
未來如果再觀察
就是把這個政策緩解之後發現完了
冷靜的效果很差
這不管怎麼鎖
大家一路飆漲停
他就必須要再下更重的手
那以後也許再做調整
最起碼現在先讓市場的氛圍
不要因為所謂處置的部分
導致股價有這麼大幅的波動
那我個人順便補充一下
我就提到被動元件提及
其實最記得幾個觀念
就是基本面有好轉
有好轉
其實有人繳出來的營收不錯
都不用用形容詞看一下營收
應該說他們特色就是前兩年有AI的時候
幾乎沒有動
今年有好轉
但是老實講
它好轉幅度是沒有到達整體上市櫃的均值
沒有均值 連均值都沒有
所以它有個問題
它股價明顯變成市場的主流
這個聽起來就不合理
就扛不住
到後來會扛不住 但是你來到現在
它都跌了七八成 六七成了
我剛好的疑問就是這個
然後又處置了拿掉了
所以結論而言就是照理講
我覺得應該說
如果我們今天不發生
第二季所谓山坡事件
就冲上去又下了
如果不发假设没有这个
我会觉得被动员现在的价格
是符合投资的原则
可是有一个比较大的问题
就因为上次有这个很大的一个山坡
上面会有很
未来会有比较大的压力
所以会导致他们未来的涨幅
其实会受到蛮大的限制
这是必然的
那加上说经过这次教训
未来大家也会理智一点
就是会发现
其实它的营收有成长
没错
可是它就是不值得股价涨好几倍
然后慢慢的大家就可以去理解了
但是我个人的角度
我会觉得回过头来
就是现在的价格是OK的
但是你不要再去期待
它未来会再回到第二季
那就老实讲不切实际
市场当时有一个不合理的激情
这个激情光这次被
打了一拳之後
應該就會明顯醒來
大家我甚至再講白一點
就是我這個
這個純粹是形容比較誇張的架構
這個被動原點上一次的這個
上一次的這個熔景也是一樣
跟這一次有點類似的故事
當時也是這個所謂日本廠
跑去坐電動車相關的被動
那個時候也是衝到1000多塊
那個已經我記得89年前之類的
然后后来当时也在讲
就是日常都跑去做高阶
然后我们台场就很肥
2018年
对 跟这一次架构很像
这次是日常都跑去做AI
所以这次我们也跟着就膨胀了
没错 故事都对
但是问题是这个架构
因为毕竟我常常讲的
要做我还是会直接买
直接吃到AI
我个人比较不喜欢买那个外溢效应
这没有一定的对错
外溢效应的涨价的
它的波动性比较大
但是它的稳定性非常的不足
有一个问
这种族群我常常讲
买红不买黑
再抢你就追
但是翻黑千万切记不要买
因为下来
可能就是整个故事结束的时候
那我还是觉得结论就是
被动员件现在其实已经慢慢回归它的价值
那如果你要把时间拉长
随着指数慢慢的往上涨
我觉得这样的期待是合理的
但是如果说你买在多少
你就觉得你要等着解套
我个人觉得这个可能会等非常长的时间
好 这个验证了
因为一开始大家会觉得
没有啊 我接后面都会上去
但是你看直播下来真的很凶
我们先解决被动元件这一题
第二题我们先来讲CPU好不好
CPU的话
昨天罗民光学有讲到一件事情
其实CPU现在大家抢的也很凶
尤其是它上有材料
像零化音等等的非常的缺
那这个东西因为不管回答台医店
就所有的大厂
它是肯定要往光通讯的这条路上走的
所以未来它会变得非常缺
还讲了一句
甚至比记忆体还要缺
那台厂的CPU说实话
在这一波股灾发生前
它就自己先股灾了
它已经是股灾的前哨战
就是CPU族群
但是CPU族群大概都打对折
我看了一下大家都打对折
可是他们有呈现一个
先跌先止跌的态势出来
那今天昨天都是盤面上
几乎非常多喷涨停的
这个族群怎么看呢
他现在打下来了
刘平光学又出来背书了
而且看起来黄伦勋对CPU的琢磨也是很深的
好CPU的故事我觉得跟我们刚刚讲的被动
被动可以套用在很多
被动可以套用在一个原则
很多族群都第二季才起涨
就两年前没起涨
功率元件也是
很多就是最起码五六种以上
全部都第二季起涨
那些都可以套用在被動元件
CPU不一樣
CPU的漲幅是比較前面的
對 它是很前面
所以它剛剛確實有就是
台股還沒股災
它自己就先股災
因為第二季資金突然要跑去買
低位接觸軍 它不是
那那個而且會有個問題
為什麼CPU修正的幅度比較大
它當時是跟著AI漲
可是它有個缺點
CPU裡面受惠的
這個程度其實很稱次不齊
那我常常講的這個不用去講哪一檔個股
CPO的個股持有的自己檢查一下
營收就知道
就是CPO裡面不到三成均值的其實蠻多的
就是營收年增率
累積上半年累積的年增率不到三成
其實蠻多的
所以結論而言確實
它從兩個層面角度出發
要記得就是CPO的部分
我們在講它通常是在講光通訊
光通訊確實現在很缺
原因就是因為
如果真的比較長之間的機櫃
它必須要靠著光線下去連接
現在還沒辦法真的用細光紙直接封裝
但是它現在就是直接走這個
所謂的光傳輸的角度
那那些中間的這些耗材
或任何材料現在確實蠻缺的
但是我剛剛提到
記得一件事情就是
這半年來
尤其在這一次經過第二季大漲壓回
我覺得可以給投資人一個
等於說一個學習的機會
就是記得
公司不管公司怎麼講
打人怎麼講 報告怎麼說
那都是一回事
有數字沒數字看就知道
你不用一直告訴我說之後有多厲害
因為我常常講的就是
我就說以前在沒有AI以前
我很在意公司告訴我說
他未来会多厉害
我就要一直去猜测到底可能性
那我可能抓出个八档十档
觉得很有机会
我在排序
把几率越高的排越前面
我就会买前段的这些公司
可是我现在这种告诉我说
之后有多厉害的公司
我老实讲我都会连懒的看
因为现在好到不可思议的公司这么多
为什么要去买一个
可能下半年明年会有多厉害的公司
然后尤其有个问题
重點是這些股價
通常在公司講或打人講的時候
他都不是在低檔了
他都已經漲了很多
大家都是漲了很多之後
才告訴你
其實他未來有很厲害
所以我覺得老實講
這些族群也不是沒有風險
就是風險其實
我個人覺得蠻高的
那他就會導
有一個問題
在第二季每天漲的時候
其實你是沒有感覺
那時候是大家市場
是沒有任何的風險意識
所以你第二季的風險
就是你沒參與
每天就是要想辦法壓的越高
就是我們收到的訊息
都是覺得自己參與不夠
自己恨不得all in開槓桿
所以那時候會有一個現象
我們那時候在講
一倍跟兩倍ETF的問題
我講兩倍的
我說那個不是核心持股就有些人就一直留言說這是我不懂其實以前回溯兩倍永遠比一倍厲害現在下跌是知道兩倍的差異在哪裡
就是這世界上沒有絕對的答案
就是在上漲的時候
不管再樂觀
你不能完全沒有風險意識
那我剛剛講的
當然結論就是
整個股市在大幅波動的情況下
漲太多一定會有比較明顯修正
当回到大家觉得压力很沉重的时候
当所有人都受不了
都要出脱的时候
其实常常就是低点的
这个接近的一个时间点
两倍我觉得可以呼应
刚刚明翰讲的一件事情
如果你只看几天没人说得准
当然超长线
因为我们讲过像所谓的0050真儿
从2014年发行
如果以这样来累积
来跟0050做对比的话
它当然报酬率是超过很多
但如果大家是用报十年的心
我觉得问题不是很大
甚至在下跌的时候勇敢去加码
而不是吱吱叫的话
我觉得问题不是很大
可惜大多数人都是在一波下跌的时候
有的开杠杆受不了
有的看到账面突然扫太多受不了
被扫出去
我觉得那个时候问题就变得很大
因为它会放大大家的亏损跟不信任
因为在股市是这样
一旦受到重创出去
就跟刚刚讲被动人犬一样
你要再回到往日荣景
需要相当长的时间跟心理建设
所以我们常常会讲说
我有看到一些听众观众会留言说
他还挺得住
反正他是现股
对不对
可是也有分
如果你的现股是像明翰
他觉得他抱的是对基本面
高度的有信任心得
和你只是在忍耐
忍耐到谈回来的时候
我终于解脱了
我可以把它卖掉
或说我经过这次我吓死
我再也不敢再这样子弄了
这是不一样的结果
我觉得这个是在心态上面
大家要非常留意的
所以你的持股是什么特性
你真的要有承受它的本事
就呼應一下槓桿型商品我也有
就真而我也有
可是我的心情就會是
它就算跌個50%
我可能也不會很緊張
如果能夠這樣的話
我覺得那當然就很健康
但是大多數人是不行的
我覺得重點在這邊
好 講了兩個產業了
我們回到財報的身上
因為呢
明開在出國的時候
第一個讓市場嚇到的財報
反而是谷歌
明明就非常好
可是它的自由現金流
從2004年以來
第一次郵政轉付這件事情
被大肆的踏罚
就是说代表AI你调高资本支出
可是你赚不回来
再来是Meta跟微软
Meta的获利表现有一点点低于预期
Meta把那个明汉的粉丝团停权了
在边呼吁一下
他不是诈骗账号
可能有人乱检举
或者我们不知道
现在明汉的粉丝团是一个停权的状态
所以有私讯他的他都看不到
先跟大家会
我们正在努力的抢救中
目前还没有抢救回来
那Meta也要再提高资本支出
再来是微软
他就做了个
当下看起来很smart的决定
他缩减了他的资本支出
说他会保持
他的自由现金流为正
微软涨了
但是我觉得最奇妙是亚马逊
亚马逊昨天晚上股价创高
他要扩大资本支出
他说他从去年
应该是06年
就今年开始
他的资本支出就已经转富了
他不在意
他觉得这样是对的
市场
不是很错乱吗
等一下哪邊我看錯了
大家都是雲端 AI這邊大幅成長
大家都覺得我應該要加大投資
有人看到市場好像不喜歡我投資就縮手
可是到底要投資還是不投資
還有就是我覺得有個結論
我是沒有編過
應該明漢也是這樣想
他們要投資就是我們的訂單
這件事情應該沒改變
是 好
這個我覺得這個是整個觀察很重要的重點
先講一下那個Meta
就是我也確實我在出國前兩三天
我的整個粉絲頁
應該說粉絲頁
其實現在看起來都正常
但是我只有一個管理員
就是我當時開的帳號
去創造這個粉絲頁
結果那個帳號
現在被Meta鎖
他說我這個是
詐騙假帳號
被人家檢舉
那我就說
我也給他我的所有證件
我也給他我的照片
怎樣
最後他還是
現在就是不解禁
所以我現在很詭異的現象
就是他說我詐騙
但是我的網頁都還在
但是我現在已經
沒辦法進去更新
那未來我們會想辦法再去處理
那另外就講到
這個整個架構呢
就是講到
我覺得四大雲端業者
我們會或者是回過頭來
我以前都常常講
在這種財報的時間點
通常有連續劇
它就是有三段
第一段一定是台積電
第二段就是四大雲端業者
第三段就回答
這幾從由AI以來
我們就是重點就在這三段
那我上次就提到
這一次的架構
跟大家回去看一下
2024年第二季
曾經完全發生過一樣的事件
就是年初開始
1、2、3月每天也是閉著眼睛漲
當然漲幅沒有
今年第二季這麼誇張
我是說這一次是超過歷史紀錄
上一次也是1、2、3月每天都是漲
它就是一條斜線
到4月開始公布財報前
還沒公布就開始慢慢的修正
不好意思在修正的過程當中
就會發生一個現象
不管你说的再好都是错
然后每天就是直接下跌
从台积电的法说
说完就杀
然后就一路杀
突然一样有一天隔开
前一天还在讲资本支出扩张
然后前一天就
大家的说法就是
花那么多钱
到底赚不赚的回来
就突然变脸了
对 然后就跌了
隔天又说
我一样资本支出突然就大涨
就表示他看到订单满满
跟现在一样
对 就是我那时候讲过
我上次就提到说
从这一次呢
从台积电的法说到
Google的财报
很明显就是这个架构
你也不用去花太多时间去拆解说
他到底错在哪里
老实讲他没有错
就是我们意思说
你四大云端业者
你还可以硬挑毛病
台积电几乎无懈可击
还不是照跌
隔天跌7个percent
我会说你就算能够勉强找出毛病所在
也不可能跌7个percent吧
所以很明显现在就是不用讲那么多
反正我就是要修正
大家就我知道
回过头来
它的利基点在哪
就是我刚刚讲的
就是上半年就涨了100个percent
它就是最该万死的
最重要的理由
所以它就是一路修正
所以中间就是等什么
等市场的氛围改变
改变了吗
最重要的重点
就是赵华刚刚提到的
很明显的就是从Amazon就看到
微软我觉得还不算真的
因为微软它选择的是
它资本支出持平
我老实讲这四家里面
微软是有点缩手的
或者是我们这样讲
可是我觉得它缩手
后来盘后大涨
市场那时候高兴
微软缩手其实也不是这一次
这两年来有一段时间
只要资本支出没有调升的
就是微软
但是后续会发生什么现象
过去它曾经有过两季不调
另外三家调
到第四次就是突然三家都继续调涨
但是微软突然大幅挑升
他把前两次没调的一次往上拉
所以结果大家都是一样
就是不断往上拉
我是说这次微软的这个借境还不够明显
重点是在Amazon
因为Amazon它好像你Google的问题
它全部都有
资本支出拉高
自由现金流转负
而且它的负的金额比Google更高
好像76亿美元
对对
它比Google还高
结果它是大涨
对
它创新高哦
所以就很明显
我当时就讲了
什麼時候叫做市場翻轉
就是市場的氛圍翻轉
我那時候講台積電確認就是出局
那時候翻轉不了
但還要等著四大雲端業者是最好的時間
如果連這一次都不行
就必須等回答
那個時間點就有點久了
中間如果這樣跌
大家可能會受不了
還要再跌20天
對 所以我就說其實
這個其實是一個連續局
就因為 Amazon 的一個角度能夠大漲
所以帶動禮拜五的這個行情
就有一個比較明顯的
這個市場就直接做追逐的動作
因為就可以知道明顯的翻轉
或者是我剛剛講的
就是投資人一個概念
就是我們切三個點
一個是上半年
一個是七月
一個是禮拜五之後
你會把這三個時間點
第二季大漲
第七月是不管任何原因
就是得修正
一直到上禮拜五
到現在
每天很多跌升的沿路漲停
在這個三個過程當中
基本面沒有任何改變
完全就是市場的心情
那這個我常常講
就是長度就得修正
我覺得是合理的
所以最後結論就是
大家本來在樂觀的時候
就必須要去一路的
這個掌控市場的風險的部分
那我常常講
就我個人的角度
我就是沒錯
我就是一直來維持高持股
我應該這樣講
因為我後來經過多次的教訓
我就是有個中心原則
我自己抓不准短线
而且我看了个这么久的市场
我从来没看过有一个人
长期而言短线是准确的
所以我没办法去抓准短线的情况下
我最后就直接放弃短线
很多族群大涨
我早就麻痹了
我跟我没关系我也不追
然后我还是持续关注
我觉得对的股票
而且我关注的是他的基本面
他的营收
他公司的说法
至于他股价提前转弱
我也不在意
因为每个人这个市场的心情变化
我懒得去管他
但我觉得没有错
你市场情绪会有好坏
但终究只要他的获利能够创高
其实后续代表的他股价还是有高点
所以回过头来最重要的重心
就是我为什么提到没有错
赵华一开始讲经过这次破坏
到底后面要怎么办
我会讲破坏的是股价
获利面完全没有任何修正
記得台積電這次的法說才講
它的營收的目標
從原本的成長超過三成
直接拉到四成
所以代表的是什麼
就是下半年你掐指一算
就是它獲利會沿路創歷史新高
它獲利能夠創歷史新高
它股價為什麼不會創歷史新高
所以我覺得是蠻合理的現象
台積電能創高
代表指數自然就能創高
回過頭來我剛剛講
為什麼要檢查自己的手中個股
上半年的營收狀況
因為如果你要很有把握
就是你持有的個股 下半年
當台積電獲利創高的時候
能夠帶 簡單而言就是AI
其實代表AI還是在創高的
那你的個股到底有沒有跟上這班列車
我覺得是很重要
如果你也在這班車上
那你絕對不要因為這段時間
它股價跌了七成八成
而你就砍 你就必須往下砍
我就常常講
就算上禮拜在下跌的過程當中不改砍
你只要檢查他的營收是維持高度成長的
大家都看得到台積電會帶動整個AI情況下
你的個股下半年獲利也會創高的情況下
哪怕上禮拜再跌不敢買
我到現在只要沒有
只能說漲幅稍微比較高一段段落之後
震盪甚至有再拉回
其實都還是一個加碼的時候
因為台股的波動真的是還是蠻大
當然美股和韓股這一次也是蠻厲害的
尤其是韓股也加入這個波動的市場
因為槓桿型的商品
我們要記得一件事情
當第二季你看著這個股票說
這也太離譜了吧
這漲到哪裡去了
那它跌下來就可能同樣的離譜
就知道它跌到哪裡
跌到地獄了也還在跌
所以上去下來都會有離譜跟情緒性的東西
它本來不應長到那
可是它長到那是因為情緒很熱
它本來不應該跌那麼深
但跌到這邊因為情緒很悲觀
从财报明明就没有变
或是财报都很好
做的事情也一样
那为什么A在跌
B不跌还创新高
可是B的创新高我觉得有意义
代表当市场的情绪
恢复一个合理的状态的时候
好成绩是会被表彰的
我觉得这件事情在亚马逊
给了我们一个信心
亚马逊会创高就代表
刚刚也讲台股其实
今天大家去看看
有一些股票已是创新高
在这么大的风浪中
不过我这边有个问题
也想要请教明翰
就是上一次其实
婉婷来的时候
我們也有聊到一個事情
我一直都有點擔心
第二季很好沒有錯
可是第三季會不會有旺季
不夠旺的問題
原因就在於
第三季很多零組件的漲價幅度
它很難像第一季第二季這麼高
然後再來是我自己知道
有些產業界的朋友也提到
在採購的步伐上
他們也會有點覺得
都讓你漲四倍五倍了
那我現在可能要跟你均衡一下
我有點受不了了
所以可能放緩了一些採購的腳步
這些是我在想
到底这波的修正跟这个有没有关系
它反映完了吗
还是当大家看到七八九月
如果营收或是获利不如预期的时候
又会再失望一次呢
我觉得整体架构应该说
这个有没有提前再反映这个
我觉得不能讲没有
但是我个人觉得
这个对后续的影响幅度
并不会有想象这么大
结论也很简单
就是应该说这次市场本来就认同可能会有这样的架构或者是换个角度講就是說這個股市的一個部分它有一個很特別的現象如果就產業的業績面
假設以前沒有AI
它一定是一二三劑越來越強
那把第四劑要的這個
所謂的電子商品的出貨
全部都在第三劑出
所以每一次的第三劑
就是業績面的高點
可是股價通常第三劑表現得並不好
這是一個過往的經驗
可是通常在修正都是第三季的比較尾段
八九月
但這一次是七月就直接開殺
那回過頭來這個
之前我也講
我也覺得說
我自己的想法也覺得
如果要開殺
繼續買等台積電過後
結果台積電還沒開把說就在跌
一開完把說直接繼續崩
所以很明顯的確實就是有提早反應
那這個故事其實也有點
之前在這兩年曾經也發生過
就回到當時我剛剛提到2024年也一樣
就是上半年漲太多財報的時候再修正
就後續等待這個第三季的時候
反而並沒有明顯的修正
所以我個人覺得結論
這個應該這樣講
股市是一個市場心情的一個總和
但是很特別的
就是股市的走勢
剛好跟大家心情的想法幾乎都是顛倒
就是過度樂觀跟貪婪的時候就要崩了
對
就是說回過頭來
我們把今年的這個情緒來演一下
就是年初的時候
演一下
大家都在講說
我看你怎麼演
應該這樣
我常常講的就是
有些人記者後來在問我說
這個指數為什麼多強
我說大家都看到哪裡看到哪裡
我說這個
我只能說
因為我去年底我還在國泰
那那個時候
反正券商每年底都要做一個明年的展望
那我當時我要負責主導這個case
然後我要負責去講這個高點在哪裡
我記得那時候抓34000多 快35000
那時候已經算市場很樂觀
算樂觀的了 沒錯吧
結果現在發現胡說八道
這個就是概念
所以我常講 這個東西真的沒有人可以知道
只能邊走邊看
確實上半年的獲利比市場好
導致一開始大家第一季
大家有點怕怕的
會覺得前兩年漲這麼多
今年到底還行不行
然後35000都還不知道能不能遇得到
結果沒想到第二劑就噴出
在噴出過程當中突然
從來沒看過這麼強勢
所以所有人都發現
沒有任何的風險意識
再來就是看誰能夠買得多
突然一修正到這裡
又有一個特色了
幾乎槓桿都被抬出去
然後突然到了上禮拜之後
所有人都保守
現在的反彈是不可能
把這個情緒完全翻轉
所以我剛剛講
上禮拜應該說7月受傷的人
這段時間再怎麼跟你講
你也不信了
你就会觉得一切都骗局
我已经被打了这么多次
我已经都已经赔钱了
对 那有个什么好处
就是我个人觉得
我觉得很有几率的
就是第三季本来该修正的
就是这一次
所以代表着每年9月会修正
过往经验就我刚刚讲的
你可以回头看
由AI以来也是一样
9月如果之前已经修正
反而9月每年会修正
反而又不修正了
所以我刚刚讲
这完全就是市场情绪的总和
但結果通常跟你想的不一樣
當你七月被修理之後
你就說算了
我就不適合賺股票的錢
我就決定那個切心準備走了
然後以後再不玩了
結果發現就後來
而且人家有講第三季
本來就是不好的時候
我乾脆休息
結果他就慢慢慢慢不斷往上走
等到你覺得樂觀的時候
通常進來又是容易去見到高點
所以我常常講就是說
第三季到底業績
有沒有可能因為漲價太多之後
動能減弱
這個是我個人覺得機率是很高的
尤其是其實老實講
最大的兇手大家也知道
就是記憶體
因為記憶體的價格真的是漲太多了
然後我常講的就是
我本來是認為
在AI伺服器因為單價高
可能影響還沒有成績那麼大
那消費性電子影響比較大
現在不是連AI伺服器都受不了了
所以到最後到底還要漲到哪裡去
那多少都還是會受到一定的影響
可是我個人覺得
我還是覺得這個動能會減緩
這是必然的現象
但不代表股價就一定會反映這個利空
因為這個是大家都能夠推估的事情
我覺得應該說最重要的關鍵點是
需求到底還在不在
因為如果需求在
只是覺得這個貴
然後呢 暫緩
這個拉貨的部分有稍微動能減緩
應該這樣講 營收你不會看到修正
你會看到的是營收本來在快速成長
它的協力慢慢變緩了
然後這樣的情況下
我覺得股市是影響是非常有限
或者是我們這樣講
如果7月沒有這一波修正
那這個會是一個非常大的一個因子
但是因為重點就是因為7月修正了
所以這個就是變成小兒科
所以我是覺得很明顯的
因為7月這種跌勢
絕對可以把剛剛提到的利空明顯消化掉
所以我要持續重申
也不用太在意這個
你要還是要關注 不斷關注
整個市場的這個需求營收狀況
還有你持有的個股的營收需求狀況
那我常講第三季是可以允許
成長的幅度變緩
但不代表可以往下
不代表可以衰退
對 不代表可以衰退
不代表可以往下翻
往下翻就是不同故事
現在大家的預期是增長的血率會變緩
但這個情況我覺得是可以接受
他不能往下彎
大家还是要留意
好 为什么要跟明翰对答案呢
因为我觉得这件事情对我来说
对判断后事是蛮重要的
因为刚刚我们前面讲了一件事
大家都在军备竞赛
好 微软是这样
收手两季
最后第三季或第四季
轰 我要追上 对不对
好 撒出来的钱
当然需求很重要
那我们以前也拆解过
其实像挥打他的客户
不只是这些云端业者而已了
他可能各国政府
中小企业
都已经AI的渗透率开始往上跑了
所以需求如果還在的話
他們撒出來的錢
有人願意去換成他們的收入回來的時候
好 這就對我們台場是絕對有利的
所以有一坨的訂單在那邊等
第三季的放緩
如果能夠在第二季的修正得到一定的疏解
就算再反映一下好了
也不認為後面的訂單會不見吧
所以堆積如山的
以及微軟要追上來的訂單
他就在那裡等
所以他就是第四季到明年的底氣
所以大家為什麼會去估
2027 2028
可以估得越来越高
就是因为这些东西还在
所以我觉得不要忘记这件事情
不要因为第二季我们历经了
我觉得有点提早来到的修正
本来还想说再撑一下
撑到第三季那个涨价放缓
大家突然吓到的时候
但没想到事情就是很难预料
提早修正之后
我们从第四季看明年
有这些的资本支出订单加持的话
亚马逊就做示范了
就是我相信公司会有再创高的能力
我是相信的
可是我們個人
不要因為在這一場的戰役裡面
受到太大的傷害
反而到那個時候又昭昭即
慌慌忙忙的去追高
我覺得他就會重演
不斷的重演
別人在賺的時候你好羨慕
然後人家快賺完的時候
我們才跳進來的這個問題
對 應該這樣講
我覺得這世界是公平的
如果你一直以來的
其實你就是這個沒有槓桿
那穩健抱著比較穩健的股票
應該說說應該這樣
以我的角度好了
我就是沒有槓桿
而且我抱的股票相對比較平穩的
會有現象
其實第二季我是明顯不如隊伍的
就是大家都去追強勢股
我其實我都沒有特別去追逐強勢組群
所以第二季的我的績效
其實是不如整體平均的
就第二季如果抱著台積電就覺得悶悶的
為什麼我不抱貝宗呢
台積電第二季是連
不要說這些強勢組群
他連指數都摸不到
對不對
說給指數因為連發科太厲害了
所以我的意思是说
我当时我也不在意
我也不会因为那些人
所以导致7月在修正的时候
我一样可以度假出国去玩
因为我就觉得还好
因为对我影响不是很大
我常常讲的就是
你要自己拿捏你自己的属性
如果你长期而言
如果我们回过头来
大家检视一下
如果你第二季该赚的时候
你都有赚到
该跑的时候
你几乎也差不多也都有跑
应该说累积这一段
你要记得
就是第二季涨这么多
才修正的幅度
说修正9000
但是今年以来
指数还是有涨超过4成
如果你的赚钱的幅度
其实没有想象的大
几乎回土的差不多
那代表着
就是要不断的去检讨
其实你是不是不适合
操作短线跟追逐强势族群
你必须要去做比较稳健
把时间拉长
但是回过头来
如果你就是上半年
该赚的都有赚第三季
当然我要不断重申
绝对没有人可以在最高点跑掉
那应该说你在高点的时候
警觉心有稍微减码
或刚跌破什么的关键点
你就有快速减码
现在下来你又有慢慢加回
你操作都非常顺利
那真的是亡中之亡
那你就持续做短线没问题
所以我常常讲
这我就一直重申
就是以前都会问我说
我的投资以来的经验
我只能说我的经验
就是最后这个结论
就是投资人该踩的雷我都踩过
该缴的学费我都缴过
那只是差别差在哪里
就是我的个性
就是我只要踩过雷
我每次我会去检讨
我这次为什么错
所以我会很想尽办法
让我上一次踩过雷不要再重犯
所以当你时间拉长之后
你自然每一次缴过的学费
都可以得到教训
你就会越来越进步
那我当时讲过去都过去
再哀怨没什么用
從今年這次七月的修正
你到底學到什麼東西
那在這一次等於說第二季的追
在往上追漲的過程當中
跟七月的修正
加總來講
老實講
其實它指數的修正
其實幅度沒有想像的大
但個股的部分
就是很大的一個波動
那你就是可以知道說
你到底屬於哪個方向的投資
那應該這樣講
我以前也是從短線強勢股
慢慢的就是
发现两个原因
第一个就是慢慢看透
第二个越来越难
因为我觉得这些强势股
可不可以赚到钱是可以的
可是赚到的钱老实讲
我自己的操作
我一直觉得我赚的不是很多
所以会有点越来越难
比例会越来越低
那应该说不是不做
只是那个比例相对比较低
所以会导致我如果要休假
我就把短线的都直接出清一下
那我都长线的
我就可以两个礼拜三个礼拜
甚至一個月 兩個月
我盤臉看都不看
我覺得那個不會影響
我簡單而言
台積電業績很好
不是我盯的
所以我覺得放假
它一樣繼續生產
所以我一樣可以輕鬆去度假
那它會負責幫我繼續賺錢
這是我的理念
所以我常常講
經過這樣的邏輯
過去都過去
重點是每一次的波動
要找到對自己能夠
讓自己更強的一個關鍵點
好 这个是一个很棒的结论
就是活动会到哪里
短线上我们有人说的准明天要干嘛
当然有人可能是
但不是我们两个人
但是为什么这段时间
我们在强调基本面没有改变这件事情
市场也会有一些比较激进的留言会说
没有改变 没有改变都跌9000点了
但是事实就是事实
但对策和做法那是另外一个事情
还有就是处理在股市里面的情绪
这个也是一个事情
因为情绪会影响到你的决策
那这一次是所谓的去杠杆
我想也差不多
我们的融资真的减得也蛮多
那韩国看起来波动
有一点告一段落了啦
真的再怎么狠的
后来等到那个海力士的会长
拿出了相近于一亿台币
去砸他们自己的股票
突然之间记忆体就好像又还好了
我觉得这些纷纷然老
在未来的一季我们还是会遇到
可是我们有帮大家先做了一些猜测
但猜测归猜测
我们是立足在基本面
还有刚刚讲的那些大厂的资本支出
不但没有改变还在增加的路上
而台湾是受贿这个基础上面来跟大家做分享的
如果我们投资没有一个基础
其实你会方向非常的凌乱
就跟为什么Google跟亚马逊
搅出一样的东西
结果市场的股价却那么大差异
但这两家都不错
这两家都是好的
都在AI的脚步上面
他们没有落对
他们都在往上走
好 今天很谢谢明翰回来
跟我們又聊了這麼多
感謝大家
也希望你的粉絲團趕快救回來
我們接下來要處理了
我們數位的人在問我了
那我們就這一集
古貨仔到這邊
今天這一集有可能來不及上字幕
也請大家多多體諒
大家拜拜
拜拜